when I tell you Simon stalinhog's the
Labyrinth is a maze you'll never Escape
I don't think I'm exaggerating a sci-fi
horror art book where a mysterious
phenomenon turns Earth into a world of
Ash and Decay the setup seems simple
likewise the characters a trio of
survivors journeying across the wastes
seem easy to relate to yet the deeper
you venture the more you realize the
Labyrinth is a complex tangle of Secrets
Mysteries and Revelations so gripping
that it never truly lets you go
so for this entry into the archive we'll
attempt to decipher this masterpiece of
Dark World building and like my videos
on stalinhag's other series you can
purchase the art book using the links in
the description now let's enter the Maze
of the labyrinth
foreign
[Music]
mysterious black Globes appear in the
sky one day their arrival so subtle and
quiet it is at first thought to be some
sort of natural Cosmic phenomenon as if
Earth has simply drifted into an unknown
part of the Galaxy yet the Spheres seem
to move in formation gliding through the
landscape like they're following a
coordinated plan of action and soon
planet Earth begins to wither the
atmosphere growing toxic over a time
scale of decades it is a chillingly
subtle apocalypse slow and almost
imperceptible all attempts to destroy
the Globes prove futile with military
crafts left warped into dreamlike
spirals of matter as if space itself has
been Twisted rendered completely
inoperable these misshapen weapons lie
forgotten in fields alongside all hope
of defeating the Spheres the Apocalypse
in The Labyrinth is so far beyond human
comprehension that the narrative could
be classified as Cosmic horror a genre
that extracts Terror from the unknowable
and otherworldly the black Globes cannot
be reasoned with rationalized or removed
they are utterly insurmountable and
astronomical nightmare that Humanity has
no hope of escaping each player gets two
completely different mazes
the profound helplessness that
incomprehensible phenomena in still can
be better understood in conversation
with the film The endless another work
of cosmic horror that follows a cult
which has emerged around a mysterious
reality bending entity like the threat
in The Labyrinth the entity in the
endless is subtle and Insidious only
perceptible in The elusive ways it warps
space yet the dread it conjures is
palpable Felton scenes where cult
members play tug of war with an unseen
force in the sky or when three moons
rise overhead a visual that like the
black Globes of the labyrinth conveys
the celestial scale of the threat
up the tower
over a decade after the globe's arrival
the sun appearing faint and green
through an ammonia-choked atmosphere
Rises over a landscape of Ash and ruin
only a small population of humans
avoided the extinction that befell the
vast majority of life on Earth yet it is
in this era of dust and Decay that the
primary Narrative of the labyrinth
begins
three protagonists set out across the
desert in a research vehicle two were
siblings and employees of kungshol an
underground facility that is one of the
last safe havens for Humanity the third
is a child and former Refugee the
siblings took in during the crisis years
all three carry with them dark secrets
from before civilizations fall
the trio Journeys towards an uninhabited
research Outpost the siblings hoping a
break and routine will help the child
who has been showing signs of acute
psychological distress at kungchol they
also plan to conduct some light research
on the change Surface after all such
Expeditions are common and should be
perfectly safe
yet there are other things in the
otherwise Barren landscape things that
don't resemble life on Earth yet seem to
be alive all the same answers to what
these entities are and why they seem so
at home in an otherwise apocalyptic
biosphere can only be found by venturing
deeper into the Labyrinth
[Music]
after a long drive across the somber
mesas the trio at last arrives at the
isolated Outpost although half buried in
Dunes of Ash the vacant station
represents one of the last safe
environments in the age of the Globes
and yet while the interior is protected
from dust and ruin the environment
doesn't feel safe in the garage a mural
depicts dandelion seeds blowing in the
wind a visual so incongruous with the
apocalyptic reality of the planet it
becomes almost Eerie this uncanniness
only grows more intense deeper within
the station where objects remain stacked
in neat rows there's a sense of
desperation in these scenes the
impossibly clean Interiors a way to
pretend that nothing beyond the facility
walls has changed as a result common
objects take on a cadaverous quality
stuck in time like insects trapped in
Amber the feeling of false can be so
extreme these Interiors can seem more
hostile than the barren desert outside
an environment that while far from
Pleasant is at the very least
straightforward the uncanniness that
these altered Interiors exude isn't easy
to put into words compared to your
typical Sinister Locale nothing about
the research station is overtly menacing
an on a cultural level we'll know what a
creepy interior is supposed to look like
there's usually cobwebs and spiders
Gothic hallways with dim lighting and
Long Shadows the perfect stage for
something to pop out for the inevitable
scare
but there's another kind of interior one
that lacks every traditional element of
a Sinister dwelling yet can be
infinitely more unsettling The Overlook
Hotel from The Shining isn't dark or
cramped or run down it's a bright
spacious clean venue yes it's haunted by
the dead both metaphorically and perhaps
quite literally but as a hotel it
honestly looks nice yet through the eye
of director Stanley Kubrick the building
feels unwell everything from the
dizzying patterns on the carpet to the
queasy colors of the rooms to the sheer
uncanniness of spaces meant to hold
thousands more people than the three
main characters broadcasts a sense of
wrongness for lack of a better word as
the leads become increasingly
psychologically distressed the
unfriendly setting feels like a
reflection of their growing mental
unwellness and perhaps even the cause
it's fitting the then that the facility
and the Labyrinth mirrors The Overlook
Hotel both in its unnerving Aesthetics
in Disturbed occupants for like the
characters in The Shining the three
leads in The Labyrinth are haunted by
ghosts from their past pushing them to
the point where they seem genuinely
unstable although for much of the
narrative it's difficult to determine
which characters are dangerous and which
are in danger at the end of The Shining
lead character Jack Torrance reaches a
point where he tries to hunt down his
family with an ax it's a looming
potential outcome that stays with you as
you read through the Labyrinth and
wonder how dark things will get before
you reach the center
Dig Dug digs his own mazes he digs for
balloon man he digs for dragons
as is suffocating tension builds within
the station the brother and sister
continue to make daily Expeditions into
the surrounding Wasteland to study
Earth's new environment and in the
emaciated remains of what was once a
city new forms of life have Arisen
amongst the wreckage gargantuan
stationary organisms Sprout from the
Ashen sand like enormous fans of coral
these life forms seem at home in the new
climate as if the Globes have
terraformed Earth to match the biosphere
of their place of origin yet these Coral
specimens are just the beginning deeper
within the Maze of the city tremendous
stalks grow inside the husks of
buildings having infested the structures
like hermit crabs occupying a shell the
tops of these stalks stretch towards the
diffused green light of the Sun the
scene evoking a photograph taken far
below the waves imagery reminiscent of
the deep sea appears throughout the lab
Earth with the suits needed to survive
on the surface evocative of not just
astronauts but also old school divers
there's a sense of incompatibility that
the land has become as unsuitable for
human life is the deepest Oceanic trench
elements of cosmic horror once again
rear their heads in these scenes as the
siblings are utterly unable to explain
the phenomena around them in one image
that didn't make it into the final art
book A mysterious squid-like creature
spreads ribbon-shaped tentacles
throughout the city there is no
understanding this new environment there
is only Danger
in this respect the Wasteland is
resonant with the Shimmer from the film
Annihilation a psychedelic region that
an alien entity transforms into a new
ecosystem the Shimmer can be deadly for
humans to Traverse yet like Earth in The
Labyrinth the Shimmer isn't devoid of
Life instead it's overflowing with new
types of organisms in fact it's left
ambiguous if the force behind the
Shimmer even comprehends that it's
causing harm an ambiguity that extends
to the Labyrinth although little Comfort
to the survivors there is a possibility
the near Extinction of humanity was just
an accident an unintentional byproduct
of some unrelated operation the new
world might be toxic to life forms
adapted to the old one but clearly some
entities prosper in these new conditions
growing to colossal sizes perhaps
whatever intelligence is behind the
change biosphere thought only of the
benefit to themselves and never entered
in the suffering of others
yet the creators of the black Globes are
not the only faction in The Labyrinth
that made callous calculations to
survive the city is haunted by organic
detritus but also the wrecks of giant
armored drones employed by the military
police during the crisis years in these
destructive weapons weren't just aimed
at the Globes
and now he's digging his way into homes
everywhere
[Music]
later in The Labyrinth we learned that
in the Years leading up to the surface
becoming completely uninhabitable panic
and Desperation spread among civilians
the air became difficult to breathe and
refugees urgently sought Shelter From
the sphere's toxins rumors of kungshol a
hermetically sealed City with room for
only one hundred thousand inhabitants
spread to the desperate masses as a
carefully constructed micro ecosystem
Kung Shaw could not hope to shelter the
many needy people who sought refuge and
so the Protectors of the facility the
siblings included made a grim
calculation one they'd spend the rest of
their lives trying to justify
a massive quarantine Zone was erected
around the site with heavily armed
guards and robots patrolling the Border
all possible threats to the project were
annihilated in order to save Humanity
the employees of kungshol believed they
needed to be inhumane for a period of
time this strategy was simple deterrence
methods of instilling fear by any means
necessary became common practice there
was no official name for what the guards
of kangshaw were doing no name was
needed and in many respects the plan was
a resounding success the streams of
people seeking safety diminished the
message had been received whatever
Misery the survivors were fleeing from
something much worse awaited them at
Kung Shaw yet cruelty does not vanish it
lingers festering in The Souls of those
who wield it and In Those whom it is
wielded against among the refugees who
suffered at the hands of kungshol was
the child killed the siblings would
later take in a decision they made to
ease their guilty consciences and forget
the darkness of their past but would
some seek to forget others shall always
remember
they think I'm trapped but I'll Escape
Tunnel runner the new video game where
you don't look down on the maze you're
in Monster
the people in The Labyrinth are a tangle
of moral complexities knots you turn
over and over in your head as you try to
unravel them struggling to reconcile
their many contradictions the characters
themselves seem lost within their own
memories unable to decide the right path
forward this conflict is represented by
a maze that comes from a computer game
the child plays which grows larger and
larger as the story reaches its climax
there is a literal maze at the heart of
The Shining as well an immense expanse
of Hedges that dominate the local
grounds for a film known for its puzzle
like storytelling it seems like a
logical inclusion yet as is the case in
The Labyrinth the Maze and The Shining
is also symbolic of the psyche of the
main characters in particular Jack
Torrance in his descent into utter
Madness perhaps the greatest mystery of
The Shining is the source of Jackson
sanity is it something he brought with
him as the film implies he abused his
spouse and child in the past is it
symptomatic of the hotel itself a
seemingly hostile Locale or is it
something Beyond Comprehension the
scheme of an otherworldly entity we
can't hope to understand this plot Point
acts as a prism with the refracted truth
appearing differently to each member of
the audience the ending of the labyrinth
is just as multifacet in fact it might
be more so because in The Shining out of
the three lead characters there's at
least a distinct villain in the form of
the ax-wielding Jack Torrance but the
Labyrinth has no villain not really just
people who had to make terrible
decisions and people who can't let go
and while you hope they'll be able to
escape to find a way out of the maze
they've all trapped themselves in
there's no exit in sight
famously in the final scenes of The
Shining Torrance becomes lost within the
very Labyrinth that represents his
winding path towards Insanity the film
ends not with the red-hot swing of an ax
but a long slow Fade Out as he succumbs
to the cold of a snowstorm the blizzard
an apparent reminder that there are far
more powerful and Elemental forces at
work in these stories than humans
the Labyrinth ends with a flood the
ammonia in the atmosphere Falls like
rain and dissolves the water Frozen
under the ash a final unexpected stage
of the changing Earth the dark liquid
Wells up in the interior of the station
drowning the red corridors and in the
midst of this catastrophe the pressure
building within the lead characters
finally bursts in a way I found both
shocking and somehow completely
inevitable considering all that came
before while I won't give away all the
final twists and turns to the Labyrinth
if you'd like to know everything that
happens you can check out the book for
yourself
[Music]
to another maze
the Labyrinth doesn't exist in a vacuum
Simon stalinhog's other works Tales From
The Loop and the electric State explore
related themes of bureaucratic
inhumanity and lingering trauma through
a lens of visually stunning sci-fi yet
though both of the aforementioned Works
have their serious elements I believe
the Labyrinth is ultimately stalinhog's
most solemn story yet one I still feel a
part of me is trapped within while all
narratives have to come to an end the
Mysteries and tragedies of the labyrinth
lingered long after the final page which
is a testament to the story's strength
all of stalinhugg's Futures are worth
experiencing and if you find these
worlds as interesting as I do you can
purchase the art books using the links
below to get the full narratives and
follow Simon stalinhog on social media
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
foreign